we've got breaking news out of
washington this morning on a brand new
immigration plan cbs news has learned
the white house and congressional
democrats will unveil a bill today that
would
reshape the laws to provide a
long-promised path to citizenship
for most of the undocumented in this
country ed o'keefe is at the white house
for us ed good morning to you what do we
know about the bill
well good morning tony this bill if
passed would establish a two-tiered
legalization system for millions of
immigrants across the country
in the first one there would be millions
of farm workers people here under
temporary protected status from
countries like el salvador or syria
and so-called dreamers those
undocumented immigrants who came here as
children
they'd be eligible for green cards or
lawful permanent residents
after three years they'd apply to be
able to apply to become citizens
all other eligible unauthorized
immigrants would be placed on an
eight-year pathway to citizenship
if they pay taxes and fees and pass a
background check but those immigrants
would have to prove they were here
before january 1st
to be eligible remember president biden
campaigned on a pledge to enact
immigration reform
early in his administration but it's
been put off a little bit obviously
by the pandemic one other notable thing
there are no republican sponsors on this
legislation being introduced today
the white house says he's willing to
work with anyone who has ideas on
immigration enforcement or border
security
two key elements of this legisl of the
immigration debate that are actually in
the bill
one other note anthony this wild weather
we're having across the country
it postponed the president's trip to
michigan today to visit a pfizer vaccine
distribution facility
he'll make that trip tomorrow all right
ed thank you